10 years ago
That was right before I got married
It was the day before the betrothal
[Applause]
[Music]
You had a car accident It was a
little bit
I begged my father
to make an afterimage of you
[Music]
[Applause]  ]
Fluorine
If you think I'm lying, why don't you go to your parents' house
Behind the tombstone, your head should be standing quietly
Then, I-
I
'm an afterimage
I'll be gone in 10 years
Yeah motor
wonder  The
next day, I silently left Ken Tokura.
Where are you going?
I wonder how he really felt about his wife I
once cried when I dreamed of his death Once again I
have to apologize to him
10 more years until I disappear Who will
come first, my father or me?  I don't know
Riko
what's wrong
[music]
Papa I
'm home